along the Tangled edge of a Brazilian
River a hunter stalks the Shadows
he is a Jaguar
a male in his prime
those who know him call him Scarface
from a wound he earned clawing his way
to Supremacy
his territory crawls with monsters
Caymans cousins of the crocodile are
waiting to grab almost anything that
comes near the water
but it's Scarface they fear
because where the land ends his hunting
ground begins
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
he is the top predator in a Land of
predators The Best of the Best
but every meal is a battle
foreign
we're only beginning to discover this
part of a Jaguar's life
in this Wetland Hideaway the secrets of
America's most mysterious big cat are
now being revealed
[Music]
dead center of South America is a
little-known slice of healing
it's a vast Wetland that brims with
wildlife
rivaling the Amazon and the plains of
Africa
it's called the Patanol on Brazil's
Western Edge
within this region is a cluster of
protected reserves
[Music]
this is the untouched heart of the
pantanal
[Music]
the land has been set aside to preserve
all life here
especially the creature at the top of
the food chain
Jaguars
[Music]
where these Predators Thrive so does
everything else
they're the biggest cats in the Americas
yet we're just beginning to understand
their lives
Jaguars are obsessively secretive but in
this special place they sometimes step
out of the Shadows
teen from National Geographic has come
here to catch them when they do
using the waterways they can penetrate
deep into Jaguar territory and track
them where they hunt
Eve winter is a veteran photographer big
cats are his passion
birdie Gregory is a wildlife cameraman
both are looking for Jaguar Behavior
that's rarely been observed let alone
filmed
these animals are incredibly special
they're only found in our Western
Hemisphere from the U.S Mexican border
all the way to Northern Argentina and
we've really come here in the dry season
because that's when all of the water is
concentrated on the rivers that means
all the prey is concentrated on these
big main rivers and that's why the
Jaguars have come to these Rivers
because well it's a fast food buffet all
along it
they've come to the right place at the
right time
but there are miles of hidden waterways
to search
it's anyone's guess where a Jaguar will
turn up next
Steve and birdie need to maximize their
chances of spotting one let's split up I
would say let's just keep in touch by
radio you see something you call me and
if I see someone I'll call you you know
they will get lucky
see on the radio
let's do it
[Music]
well Steve heads up the cuyaba river
birdie tries his luck down a narrow side
Channel
strategy is simple
scan the Riverbanks for any sign of cats
[Music]
the water is where they hunt so the
water's edge is where they'll often be
Upstream birdie has an early Stroke of
Luck
[Music]
relaxing in plain view on the back
and she's not alone
she has a cub an adolescent male about a
year old
living in the protected Reserve they
don't experience humans as a threat
so they tolerate birdie in his boat
Jaguar Cubs stick with their mothers for
the first few years
she weaned him six months ago
but he still counts on her to catch his
dinner and keep him safe
[Music]
foreign
he's going to be bigger than she is soon
but inside he's still all come
[Music]
15 meters away less than 50 feet and
they're so relaxed that I've managed to
actually get out the boat and sit here
there's the female there
and there's the Cub just over there
I'm just so grateful to them for giving
us just a little window into the secret
life of the Jaguar
what an incredible experience
[Music]
it's her job to teach him everything he
needs to survive in the potential
[Music]
for the moment he's learning a trick to
keep cool during the sultry days of the
dry season
by climbing into the Treetops they can
catch the slight breeze over the water
[Music]
right now mother and cubs share the
closest bond that any two Jaguars can
have
[Music]
yet a little over a year from now she'll
turn him away to live a solitary life
[Music]
no one can say for sure who the father
of this Cub is
because males and females don't stay
together after mating
it's most likely she mated with the
dominant male in her territory
around here that means one male in
particular
Steve's been dead set on fighting him
the one with the distinctive battle scar
if there's any cat that looks like a
beat-up prize fighter you know it's this
guy
if a male wants to grab territory in
breeding rights he has to be
intimidating and ready to fight
Scarface is all that
he Now commands a territory of about 40
square miles
other males enter at their peril
s are permitted they'll seek him out
when they're ready to mate
but right now Scarface is thinking about
food and Steve wants to get shots of him
tackling a caiman
the trick is figuring out when and where
it's going to happen
there's got to be keeming down there
[Music]
it may be three or four days since
Scarface last eight
and he looks like he's getting serious
about his next meal
[Music]
foreign
even a skilled Hunter like him only
scores about 15 percent of the time
as the reigning male he claims exclusive
access to the best hunting spots
still he can't keep track of it all at
once
while he's focused on food he's failing
to notice something happening just
Upstream
[Music]
there's an intruder
a young male has sauntered into
scarface's territory
Jaguars want to be close to water
now that it's the dry season they're
gathering around the rivers that are
still running
these anti-social cats are starting to
bump into one another
dominant male like Scarface won't stand
for it
a protected corner of Brazil's patent
all has opened a window into the lives
of jaguars the most secretive big cat in
the Americas
National Geographic photographer Steve
winter and cameraman Bertie Gregory have
come to catch them in action
there's no place like this in the whole
range of the Jaguar
this is the jewel in the Jaguars Crown
right here the pontanal there's a future
for the species in this incredible Oasis
they've tracked a big male they call
Scarface
[Music]
they've also spied a younger male
invading the older cat's territory
[Music]
he can smell scarface's presence all
around
but young males can get cocky
he wants to claim a hunting ground of
his own and get better access to females
that's something he needs to earn
first step is becoming a strong Hunter
his mother gave him the basics
but the learning curve is steep
when going after such dangerous prey a
little hesitation is Justified
Brazil's answer to crocodiles yakari
Caymans have 74 teeth and one of the
strongest bites in the animal kingdom
Caymans usually train their powerful
jaws on fish
this big river that keeps flowing in the
dry season guarantees a steady supply
plentiful fish means plentiful Caymans
which is good news for Jaguars
but catching them means diving into
their realm where they are the killers
with one swipe of its tail a caiman can
drag a victim to the bottom and stay for
15 minutes or more
[Music]
to become a caiman Hunter this young
male has to master the ambush
make a powerful attack and a swift kill
proof that true Hunters are made not
born
[Music]
[Music]
at least there are turtles frogs and
fish to tie them over while he gets the
hang of it thank you
[Music]
right now there are bigger things to
worry about
Scarface is closing in
the young male could decide to pick a
fight
it depends how ambitious he's feeling
today is not the day
for Scarface the scent of the Intruder
lingers like a personal insult
he lays down a reminder that this is his
turf
[Music]
a spray of urine is like planting a flag
in the ground
other Jaguars recognize his individual
scent and they can tell he's dominant by
how far and wide he leaves his mark
so even if they never meet him they
definitely know he's a cat to reckon
with
swapping chemical calling cards is a lot
safer than fighting
Scarface reclaims his favorite hunting
spot without lifting a palm
[Music]
foreign
just up River the mother Jaguar is
facing a challenge of a different kind
she has to hunt for two
her cub hangs back in the forest while
she heads toward the river in search of
a Target
Caymans are her Top Choice too but the
Wetland also offers a less toothy
alternative
capybaras
they're the largest rodent on earth like
a giant guinea pig
[Music]
whether river banks are low in green
they graze on Fresh grass and aquatic
plants
and cattle tyrants graze on them
these birds hitch a ride to catch any
insects the capybara stirs up
in turn the capybara gets relief from
ticks and biting flies
munching peacefully with a bird riding
piggyback a capybara looks like it's
just waiting to become a Jaguar's dinner
but they're no easier to catch than a
caiman
their feet are partially webbed for fast
swimming
and they hang out in big family groups
for protection
anyone that spots a Jaguar lets out an
alarm bark
and they all die for deep water
[Music]
ears nose and eyes are all set high so
they can swim with just the tops of
their heads exposed
once they're in the river
there's no catching them
the mother Jaguar has spotted one high
and dry on a sandbar
it's a male on his own without a group
to sound the alarm
it's just a bit out of range and she's
built for power more than speed
it all comes down to who's faster on the
draw
for Jaguar life and death boils down to
skill as a hunter
they learn to gauge the odds of success
versus a waste of precious energy
this mother decides the odds are too low
to justify the effort
her hungry Cub will have to wait
[Laughter]
[Music]
along the kuyaba river the dominant male
called Scarface is also struggling
[Music]
he hasn't caught a meal in nearly a week
[Music]
his streak of bad luck is no less
frustrating to the photographers who
have come here to film him on the hunt
we're up to about 14 failures with
Scarface now
so we're getting closer to the one
that's going to work
Steve yeah yeah this isn't working
what's going on how many times can this
guy fail
I mean in the last few days that means
he's now lost what three or four kills
he's friggin hungry right so he's gonna
start getting desperate I mean getting
pictures of splashes is fine but we need
the real deal so we'll just go
they leave Scarface to catch up with the
mother Jaguar who's also hungry
by the time they reach her she's already
got a capybara
[Music]
a cub waiting somewhere in the forest
Forest
at around 90 pounds it will hold both of
them for two or three days
for birdie and Steve another day ends
without catching a complete hunt
[Music]
for humans and big cats success demands
patience
[Music]
it's morning and Stephen birdie set out
to check the spots where they've sighted
Jaguars before
[Music]
there's so much more to see along the
river than just cats check it out
jabbery Stork on the beach
absolutely massive
so many animals find a home here because
the land has been preserved for Jaguars
foreign
[Music]
the best thing about protecting the
Jaguar you know this big apex predator
is that by protecting it you protect
everything underneath
[Music]
preserving jaguar habitat even helps to
save an endangered rival predator
where jaguars Thrive so do giant river
otters
this whole family spent the night in a
den under the riverbank
now they're out for the day
John Alters are a really good indicator
species you know one that shows the
health of the ecosystem because if you
think if there's 20 individuals in a
family each of them is six feet long
they each need about eight pounds of
fish every single day that's a lot of
fish that they need to support
themselves so if you've got giant otters
that means you've got a really really
healthy ecosystem
the river brings a steady supply of
catfish perch and piranha to their
doorstep
there's sloppy eating attracts
freeloaders
some can get pretty aggressive
others try to be a bit more subtle about
it
[Music]
even the young otters aren't above
begging
but these pups are old enough to do
their own fishing so they get no special
favors
[Music]
breakfast over they haul out and relax
on the bank
chance to socialize and strengthen
family bonds
On Solid Ground they're like sitting
ducks
Jaguars wait for a chance like this
[Music]
foreign
shatters the peaceful morning at the
otter pond
it's red alert
[Music]
come on
[Music]
the youngsters duck into the den while
the adults form a battle line
the female Jaguars torn between her
Hunter's Instinct and caution
if she caught one on its own especially
a young woman she might go after it
let the Otters let her know they're way
ahead of her
sure she's bigger but they're much
better swimmers
and they'll attack as fiercely as a pack
of dogs
jumping into this pool would be a huge
mistake
she sees their point
they send her off with a few final
insults
the Jaguar head doesn't have many
enemies
but when they come face to face with
giant otters giant otters are one of the
few animals here that can put up a
pretty good fight
an experienced Jaguar doesn't usually
bother with otters
so Steve sticks to the main river
Channel where Scarface is sure to be
hunting caimans
his guide pu grew up on this River and
knows every Bend he's got eyes like you
wouldn't believe we'll be flying along
they'll just stop and go Jagged and I'm
like how do you see that
amazing we've been at this tree so many
times in this area
where Jags have been hunting right in
there because Cayman hang out in there
yes I can hear you fine what's up
yeah
this Jaguar was spotted where Scarface
often hunts it's a good lead but if they
don't get there fast they could miss the
moment he's really intent on Hunting
which is what we want so it's a ways
down river but we're just gonna go full
for and get there as fast as possible
upriver Steve finds birdie
now it's just a matter of finding the
cat
Steve which scoop
um said the fishing boat just said that
they saw a big male jump in and they
went on to go fishing and
he's in the forest somewhere I mean it's
a tough area
to follow him man yeah I mean we saw
Scarface here what a day ago two days
ago hunting right here and now he's
hunting again
if he wanted to a Jaguar could disappear
in the forest just a few feet away
[Music]
Scarface is hungry
and that brings him out into the open
foreign
[Music]
yet another Cayman slips from his grasp
but today Scarface seems different more
intense
[Music]
he's a cat on a mission and that mission
is survival
he hasn't eaten in a week and his hunger
drives him to an extreme hunting
strategy
[Music]
so far he's done his stalking from land
but now he's hunting completely in the
water battling the powerful current
searching for any hidden Cayman
truly a master of Two Worlds
birdie and Steve have never seen this
tactic before
Scarface is absolutely incredible
he's swimming looking for a Cayman
[Music]
he's Beast Master
foreign
[Music]
I always think of you know big cats as
being terrestrial animals you know they
live in jungles and forests
but this guy's almost like a marine
mammal
think that he's hunting mainly swimming
in the river with the focus and the
strength to swim upstream yeah it's
pretty mind-blowing
[Music]
thank you
Steve winter and Bertie Gregory are on
the trail of a very hungry Jaguar
they know he can unleash a powerful
attack but this is a sheer test of
endurance
he's battling the current searching for
any Cayman on the Riverbank or bottom
you've never seen anything like it
Scarface must have some I don't know a
mile two miles straight into this really
strong current
Jaguars are like bodybuilders you know
some cats are built for Speed like the
leopard the cheetah but a Jaguar is
built for power and this guy shows it
he's tough but fighting the river takes
a toll
after two hours Scarface looks exhausted
can you see him now I lost him no no
he's lost okay so what's the plan
because he went in here so are we
waiting here and you're going around the
corner or you want to go around the
corner we'll wait here no I don't really
care who does what all I want to do is
get him
birdie and Steve aren't about to give up
but they can only guess the Jaguar's
next move about a hundred feet Upstream
there's prey oh there's a Cayman
but has Scarface seen it we see food it
doesn't mean he does
we'll just wait
where are you big boy
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
the deadliest aquatic predator in the
Patanol is no match for Scarface
after a battle to the death the struggle
isn't quite over
[Music]
like all Jaguars Scarface is a secretive
cat
he won't rest until he hides his Kill
from scavengers and thieves somewhere up
the bank and in the forest
but the Cayman is 120 pounds of dead
weight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one final Herculean effort and he gets
his meal
[Music]
birdie and Steve have also gotten their
reward
that moment was absolutely one of a kind
the craziest thing to me was how he hits
that game and the bomb goes off water
goes everywhere
and then there was that Eerie silence
when he'd gone in the water with the
Cayman he'd obviously got it somehow
he's under the water
foreign
think that was the most incredible thing
I've ever seen yeah that was one of the
most incredible displays of Power by an
animal I've ever seen way to go Scarface
Scarface keeps his dominance on this
stretch of river
but even that's just a means to an end
the Ultimate Prize is still elusive
[Music]
on the banks of the kuyaba river
Scarface has sated his hunger
[Music]
but now he's feeling an urge of a
different guy
[Music]
there's an alluring new presence lurking
nearby
[Music]
her territory overlaps his but she's
been waiting for the right time to make
her presence known
[Music]
Jaguars usually avoid one another
[Music]
but when she comes into estrus it's like
a switch gets flipped
[Music]
these two tough loners turn into
lovebirds if only for a short time
[Music]
for the next week or two they think of a
little else
they could mate up to a hundred times a
day
then again it only takes nine seconds
[Music]
scarface's Legacy grows a little bit
more
in this Reserve their offspring will
grow up safe with plenty of prey
[Music]
in other parts of the Palm now Jaguars
don't have it so good
Steve and birdie have just received news
of Jaguar activity to the South outside
the reserves
with Scarface occupied they follow the
trail
out here the cats confront dangers that
Scarface seldom has to face
[Music]
open to cattle ranching
Jaguar territory is filled with an
unnatural irresistible prey
killing a Jaguar is illegal in Brazil
but when a Jaguar preys on livestock
ranchers take revenge to protect their
livelihood
in one of the ranches a Jaguar has
killed a cow
it's a bad situation but also an
opportunity to see how jaguars live on
the fringes of the human world
where humans are close by Jaguars appear
to be more wary of coming out in
daylight
whatever killed this cow is probably
waiting until Nightfall to come back
so Steve and birdie settle into weight
what keeps us sitting here
is as Steve said the passion is knowing
that by sitting here
maybe maybe we'll get to see something
incredible
Maybe not maybe you will see nothing
other than this very very dead cow
as evening Falls they get a surprise
it's not the hunter that appears
it's a cub
followed by another
[Music]
foreign
they're about 16 months old a bit older
than the Cub back in the reserve
their mother made this kill
she keeps a watchful eye as her young
ones eat their fill
[Music]
as night falls over the patent all
birdie switches to a new low-light
camera
for the first time he's able to see what
these secretive cats get up to at night
[Music]
under the cover of Darkness the Cubs
relax
[Music]
well fed and protected by Mom they share
a moment of Carefree contentment
[Music]
all right
[Music]
but they don't know this meal comes at a
huge price
[Music]
they're learning from their mother to
hunt cows and they're developing a taste
for it
one day this Behavior May cost them
their lives
foreign
[Music]
this is why the preserved areas of the
patent now are so critical for Jaguar
survival
inside the borders there are no cows no
human threats and plenty of natural prey
the mother and her single Cub can rest
easy
foreign
under her care he will grow to become a
powerful Cayman Hunter
[Music]
the young male that invaded scarface's
territory has retreated to the fringes
[Music]
beginning to find his place
one day he may prove a worthy adversary
to Scarface
but not just yet
for now this tough battle scarred male
hangs on to his rule
and to his role as guardian of the
pantanal
Jaguars will care for the land for as
long as the land keeps Jaguars
[Music]
[Music]